hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen we've made it through the
indulgent holidays and bikini season
will be here before we know it but why
wait until summer to enjoy a nice crisp
cold beer now I know what you're
thinking we have New Year's resolutions
to uphold but I say all the more reason
to indulge the BeerBelly myth is so 2014
based more on the kinds of foods we
associate even with fear like nachos
potato chips pizza than anything
inherent about beer itself in reality
beer is low in sugar it's made with all
natural ingredients and ounce for ounce
it actually has fewer calories than wine
or spirits meaning if you sip and savor
you can mindly enjoy less also I bet you
didn't know that consuming one to two
beers a day has been linked to a reduced
risk of weight gain and heart disease
the key however is to enjoy it regularly
and not abstain all week long and then
binge on Saturday night and of course to
skip the bar food and favorite more
balanced meals
case in point my Brussels sprout and
apricot slaw with beer pesto vinaigrette
using beer in my salad dressings lets me
cut back on fat without compromising
flavor you're gonna love the result
first I shred a few cups of Brussels
sprouts fennel and apple and mix them
together with some finely diced dried
apricots then into my food processor I
grind my blanched whole almonds and
Parmesan cheese
then add in my parsley almond oil honey
lemon juice thyme leaves salt and pepper
and of course my favorite beer as a
simple rule of thumb loggers tend to go
best with sweet light greens pilsners
with peppery greens wheat beers with
fruity flavors and English ales with
earthy veggies and grains I'm using a
triple which works really well with
those cruciferous vegetables creamy
dressings and stone fruit when ready to
serve I toss the greens in the pesto and
garnish with toasted sliced almonds and
shaped Parmesan cheese
whoever said you can't make friends with
salad head never put a little beer on
top mindfully enjoying your favorite
beer with this Brussels sprout and a
profs law is total proof that getting
back on track before summer doesn't have
to suck thanks so much for watching guys
for great healthy recipes be sure to
subscribe to my channel and I'll see you
next time Abbey's kitchen